so we have our scale again and we've got
some masses on the left-hand side and
some masses on the right-hand side and
we see that our scale is balanced we
have the same total mass on the
left-hand side that we have on the
right-hand side instead of labeling the
mystery masses as question mark I've
labeled them all X and since they all
have an X on it we know that each of
these have the same mass but what I'm
curious about is what is that mass what
is the mass of each of these of each of
these mystery masses I guess we could
say and so I'll let you think about that
for a second how would you figure out
what the mystery mass but what each what
this x value actually is how many
kilograms is the mass of each of these
things what could you do to either one
or both sides of this scale and I'll
give you a few seconds to think about
that so you might be tempted to say well
if I could end up with just one mystery
mass on the left-hand side then it's
going to be equal to and if I keep my
scale balanced then that things going to
be equal to whatever I have on the
right-hand side and that part would
actually be a true statement but then to
get only one mystery of one of these
mystery masses on the left-hand side you
might say well why don't I just remove
two of them you might just say well let
me just remove why don't I just remove
we do it a good color for removing why
don't I just remove that one and that
one and then I'll just be left with that
right over there but if you just removed
these two then the left-hand side is
going to become lighter or it's going to
have a lower mass than the right-hand
side so it's going to move up and the
right-hand side is going to move down
and then you might say ok I understand
whatever I have to do to the left-hand
side I have to do the right-hand side in
order to keep my scale balanced so you
might say well why don't I remove two of
these mystery masses from the right-hand
side but that's a problem too because
you don't know what this mystery mass is
you could try to remove two from this
but how many of these blocks represent a
mystery mass we actually don't know but
you might then say well let's see I've
got three of these things here if I if I
essentially multiply what I have here by
a third or if I only leave a third of
the stuff here and if I only leave a
third of the stuff here then the scale
should be balanced if this has the same
mass if this has a total mass as this
then one third of the
total mass is going to be the same thing
as one third of that total mass so let's
remove so let's just keep only one third
of this here so that's equivalent to
multiplying by one third so if we're
only going to keep one third there we're
going to be left with only one of the
masses and if we only keep one third
here let's see we have one two three
four five six seven eight nine masses if
we only if we multiply this by one-third
or if we only keep 1/3 of it they're
one-third times nine is only three or
it's three so we're going to remove
these and so we have one third of what
we originally had on the right hand side
and one third of what we originally had
on the left hand side and they will be
balanced because we took one-third of
the same total masses and so what you're
left with is just one of these mystery
masses this this X thing right over here
whatever X might be and you have three
kilograms on the right hand side and so
you can make the conclusion and the
whole time you kept this thing balanced
that X is equal to three